Chris Cuomo is shutting down his haters
hard I feel better than I deserve the
CNN anchor was diagnosed with cope in
nineteen nearly two weeks ago I tested
positive scare yes as you might imagine
but better me than you and he's
continued to film his show cuomo
primetime out of his basement where he's
still in quarantine away from his wife
and their kids and a wife i my kids
thank god didn't have it look how lucky
i got here
chris recently shared this clip from his
show to instagram talking about Passover
and the current global pandemic the
story of this holy day is more relevant
to the secular reality of this entire
country than perhaps it ever has been
the story of Passover is a literal
passing over of the Angel of Death right
he captured the clip quote Passover in
the age of another plague the Jews were
warned to mark their doors with blood to
avoid having the firstborn taken it was
the worst of the plagues this pandemic
is plague like okay it is casting a
shadow over everyone's door and there is
no mark that it seems to respect well
that's why one internet troll went in on
Chris in the comments writing praying
this plague take you out seriously what
the f man rude and Chris he fired back
with a clap back to end all clap backs
prepare for disappointment
punk punk I haven't heard someone say
Punk since grade school but I'm so here
for it I've had a fever you've had a
fever but 102 103 103 Plus that wouldn't
quit and it was like somebody was
beating me like a pinata
of course Chris has been tough and
resilient as he battles the virus the
Beast comes at night and my fever has
gone up a couple of degrees and like the
last 30 minutes nights are tough and
he's been super candid with his audience
about symptoms it was freaky
what I lived through last night and it
may happen again tonight doctor says may
happen like five eight times chris said
his fever got so bad he hallucinate
Adana lee thought he was talking to his
late
dad I was shivering so much I chipped my
tooth so the Sun comes up I'm awake I
was up all night was wrong I'm telling
you I was hallucinating I said my dad
was talking to me I was seeing people
from college people I haven't seen it
forever it was it was freaky what I
lived through last night and it may
happen again tonight doctor says it may
happen like five eight times you know I
get it now and if you match that with
chest constriction of people can't
breathe I totally get why we're losing
so many people and why our hospitals are
so crowded and he said a ton of weight
I've lost 13 pounds in three days now
I'm a big guy I started off at 230
pounds
my wife is feeding me like you know we
were still in the dating phase you know
so it's not like I'm not nutrition I'm
eating and drinking constantly I'm just
sweating it out and it's the sickness
and while Chris may have a few trolls
coming at him online he and his older
brother Andrew Cuomo the governor of New
York have also gained a lot of fans
obviously the fever has affected your
mental capacity in yep andrew has been
popping in to his brother show pretty
regularly and viewers are loving it you
should have one every day yes I have
been I know you haven't known oh yes
sorry a source recently told et quote
the brothers are aware of the Cuomo
crush and hashtag Cuomo brothers they
think it's cute and playful both
brothers know the responsibility they
have during this global crisis and they
take their job seriously they both
respect what the other does and both are
extremely proud of one another despite
the ribbing people will be remembered
for how they stepped up right now and
what they did and what they didn't and
I'm very proud of you big brother yeah
[Music]